dejan constancia de las evidencias que
encuentran el tipo de calibre del arma y
proyectil los inspectores de la fiscalía
documentan ataques contra objetivos
civiles en la invasión rusa en ucrania
[Música]
el equipo del fiscal del distrito
recorre cada día las calles del barrio
más devastado en el frente de batalla
mira por esto mismo me preguntaba
mejor a los empleados entrevistan a
vecinos inspeccionar apartamentos con su
permiso del señor trozos sueño máximo es
uno de los investigadores que trabajan
en el distrito de keaps que donde se han
identificado cerca de 700 ataques contra
objetivos civiles
investigamos crímenes de guerra en este
proceso establecemos la naturaleza del
daño si el daño es causado por un
proyectil quedará claro que es un crimen
de guerra
pero no es tan fácil para que en un
futuro esas investigaciones puedan
proseguir tienen que probar la
procedencia y la intencionalidad de ese
ataque de ahí su afán en documentar cada
detalle con expertos de distintos
ámbitos
inspeccionamos la escena y lo dejamos
grabado en vídeo vamos a inspeccionar
por ejemplo la casa que está detrás de
mí lo grabaremos y tomaremos fotos
mediremos el tamaño de las pruebas
gracias a expertos militares y ex y
quitan la mayoría de crímenes de guerra
investigados en la zona de jarquil son
por bombardeos
lanzamiento de misiles de forma
indiscriminada a edificios de viviendas
como esta que estamos viendo en estos
momentos completamente destrozado el
fiscal general de toda la región es el
encargado de las investigaciones que
pasarán después a un tribunal militar
[Música]
luego será el tribunal militar el que
investiga los casos donde rusia alza dow
armas prohibidas en nuestra región la
mayoría bombas de racimo no son por un
robo rama no sólo en esta región de
jarquín la fiscalía está investigando
más de 1.300 casos de posibles
bombardeos rusos a objetivos civiles
desde que empezó la invasión rusa en
ucrania